So leute ich bin mal noch eine stunde da ja vielleicht sogar ein bisschen länger
Eineinhalb schon aber wisst ja 22 uhr boomer müde boomer bett boomer schlafen und so weiter und so fort
und max und films alle am start
Hogan kein stream ja ich habe nichts geplant heute gar nichts
wir können ein bisschen schwätzen wir können vielleicht noch das eine oder andere
video gucken
Sagen da fehlt da fehlen dann noch ein paar tabs
Schön dass du da bist ich bin aber nur eine stunde oder eineinhalb stunden
Dann gehe ich penne hast du mal was mit laura gemacht ja
habe ich
ich glaube
Sogar im stream
guck mal
vor vier jahren
aber nur aber mit laura was
gebaut
Ja das ist sie hier
Ja vor vier jahren aber was war damit damit gebaut also ja habe ich auch schon ohne stream gemacht
Aber ich habe aktuell nichts im einsatz was laura verwendet
Habe ich nicht
welches gateway gar kein geld weil ich habe peer-to-peer kommen und also nicht per tippe also
point to point kommunikation gemacht
Zwischen zwei selbst installierten laura kisten
gar kein gateway
Nein habe ich mir nicht gekauft aber ich werde es auf jeden fall spielen bin mir nur am überlegen ob ich nicht
Vielleicht lieber sogar auf emulator spielen soll
Wenn das gut funktioniert
Einfach auflösung und mehr fps
Versuche gerade meine proxbox automatisiert zu professionellen
den proxmox server selbst automatisch zu professionieren oder eine vm
Auf proxmox zu professionieren
Weil den proxbox not aufzubauen stelle ich mir mit terraform tatsächlich relativ schwierig vor da glaube ich wäre wahrscheinlich so was wie ansie besinniger die vm
Ja du kannst doch bei proxbox bestimmt das kvm interface exposen
Und dann kannst du das terraform modul für kvm verwenden dom tendo macht es mit emulat
wirklich
Das ist doch der der nintendo fanboy nummer eins der spielt wirklich
Der spielt wirklich emulator auf seinem
channel ja
Das muss jetzt nachgucken das glaube ich gar nicht
das ist das ist offen unglaublich
das ist upscale auf 4k
Ja gut hier ist es schlecht zu erkennen das könnte genauso gut auf der switch sein
das ist upscale keine ahnung ob das wirklich das ist
Keine ahnung ob das auf dem emu ist
Der wird das noch im leben nicht auf dem emu spielen
Das kann ich mir kaum vorstellen
Weil der ist ja auch ganz dicke mit nintendo und nintendo fängt das bestimmt nicht geil wenn irgendwie eines der größten let's plays auf dem emu läuft
wäre das glaube ich nicht
ich meine
Ich würde in 60 ich würde es auf jeden fall höhere auflösung und 60 fps der switch bevor
ok
bevorzugen
Ich finde es auch wenn man es gekauft hat überhaupt nicht verwerflich
Die switch ist halt schon ein bisschen in die jahre gekommen jetzt
naja
Was ist hier los nix steht auch im titel schon drin
Du hast den prime benutzt als oft nice dankeschön für den prime sub
Wo ich guck gerade mal wen haben wir hier noch wen habe ich noch übersehen
Puzzle master hat resubscribed
x gollum xxx hat resubscribed
tway
alles nicht gesehen vorhin
Was war auch in der zeit wo ich oft war
pockey subscription
Ja leute also ich habe wie gesagt nichts nix geplant für den stream
Wir können zwei sachen machen entweder ihr habt irgendwelche spannenden
themen
questions oder irgendwas
Wir können uns auch ein paar
it news sachen angucken oder noch ein paar videos hier aus der langen watch history
ansonsten was gibt es spannendes diese woche ist ein feiertag also nächste woche ist ein feiertag
ich glaube der donnerstag wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege guck mal wie kacke der windows
kalender ist er zeigt nicht mal feiertage an ich glaube das hier ist ein feiertag nächste
woche das heißt ich muss tatsächlich nur 123 tage arbeiten ja feiertage hessen 2023
mai ist das das ist vater tag oder das ist das vater tag glaub schon montag sagt montag sagt
warum muss das alles montag sein warum muss pfingst montag montag sein kann mir das irgendjemand
erklären was soll der mist warum ist pfingst montag immer montags 44 feiertage am montag wo
wo mir meine Vier-Tage-Woche gar nichts bringt.
Scammed, Alter.
Scammers.
Sollen wir Hotfix rausbringen?
Ja, aber schleunigst.
Braucht das Ticket für auf.
Ja, was wäre denn besser gewesen?
Montag ist einfach der beste Tag,
um nicht arbeiten zu gehen.
Montag kommen alle aus dem Wochenende,
sind super motiviert, wollen tausend Sachen machen.
Und Freitag ist ein Scheiß-Tag.
Freitag macht eh keiner immer was.
Freitag ist der entspannteste Tag der Woche.
Warum soll ich...
Nee, ja, das Feiertage ist doch egal.
Freitag ist der entspannteste Tag der Woche.
Warum soll ich da frei haben?
Nee, Mittwoch ist auch dumm.
Da musst du ja quasi Montag, Dienstag arbeiten,
Donnerstag, Freitag hast du ja gar nicht am Stück frei.
Nee, nee, Montag ist der beste Tag.
Das Dumme ist halt nur, dass so viele Feiertage Montag sind.
Na gut, irgendwas.
Irgendwas ist immer.
Aber ich will mich mal nicht beschweren.
Vier-Tage-Woche ist eh sehr pock.
Inklusive Kohle, die es trotz vier Tage gibt,
ist sehr pock.
Also, ich meine, ich bin wirklich...
Also, ich müsste eigentlich wirklich rundum zufrieden sein.
Bin ich ja eigentlich auch, ja?
Ist doch nicht so...
Bin ich ja.
Sage ich ja oft genug, also...
Was das angeht, wenn man über einem gewissen...
über einem gewissen...
Schnitt ist, ist eh alles wurscht.
Außer man ist der Hardcore-Karriere-Kreiselgrinder.
Dann nicht.
Aber ich glaube, keiner von uns ist der Hardcore-Karriere-Kreiselgrinder, oder?
Unter 70 Stunden, ja.
Die High-Performer-Criner-Mindset ist am Start.
Aber wenn du so überlegst, habe ich ja eine 70-Stunden-Woche.
Überleg mal, guck mal.
Ich bin teilweise...
Naja, okay, 70 vielleicht bis...
Na, wobei, sag das mal nicht.
Es gibt Wochen, da streame ich teilweise...
Fünf Tage, vier, fünf Tage, drei Stunden.
Na gut, da komme ich aber auch nicht auf 70 Stunden.
Wow, warum ist das so laut?
80.
WTF?
Ja, viel besser.
Jetzt aber die Musik zu leise.
Kackel.
So ist okay.
Komm in die Gruppe.
Das ist out.
Ich sehe total wenig solcher...
solcher komm in die Gruppe...
Scam...
Werbung...
Dinger irgendwo noch.
Oh, Leute, ich bin jetzt schon müde.
Schlimm.
Also, du hast mittlerweile 2460 Stunden gestreamt.
Das heißt, das wären 308 Arbeitstage.
Krass, oder?
Aber das in fünf Jahren.
Wie findest du eigentlich, wenn Leute so tun, als ob Aufgaben viel weniger Zeit gebraucht haben?
Also, du hast 20 Stunden gebraucht und tust deinen Chef so, als ob das nur 10 Stunden waren.
Ähm...
Ich kenne es ehrlich gesagt nur umgedreht.
Dass Arbeit künstlich aufgebläht wird, was mehrere Gründe haben kann.
Ja, zum einen, dass man genug Luft hat, andere Sachen zu machen.
Und einfach ein bisschen entspanntere Planungssachen hat.
Und es oftmals weniger Stress gibt, wenn man nur eine Sache einplant und die dann auch macht, anstatt fünf Sachen einzuplanen, davon nur vier zu schaffen.
Also, insofern...
Ich kenne...
Ehrlich gesagt, hauptsächlich den umgedrehten Fall, dass im Business-Umfeld so die Aufgaben extrem aufgeblasen werden.
So einfache Sachen werden so getan, als dauert es ewig.
Aber ansonsten, warum sollte man das denn machen?
Was genau ist der Vorteil davon, das so zu machen?
Außer, dass man...
Dass nicht richtig anerkannt wird, wie viel Arbeit man reinsteckt.
Und im Zweifelsfall noch doof gefragt wird, ja, was machst du eigentlich die ganze Zeit?
Gut, ich meine, man hat den Vorteil, vielleicht kann man mal kurz besonders schlau erscheinen beim Chef, aber in der Regel interessiert die überhaupt nicht, wie lange das gedauert hat, wenn es im Rahmen ist, sondern nur, dass es am Ende funktioniert.
Ja, weiß nicht, habe ich jetzt so bewusst noch nicht mitgekriegt, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ich kenne nur den umgedrehten Fall.
Ich meine, was ich aus eigener Erfahrung kenne, ist, zu sagen, ah, ich weiß, wie das geht.
Es ist easy, ich mache das mal schnell und dann dauert es fünf Tage.
Und das habe ich am Anfang nicht gemeint mit schnell.
Mit schnell meinte ich zwei, drei Stunden, aber man verschätzt sich da selbst manchmal ganz gut.
Oftmals, weil halt noch mehr dranhängt, als so die eigentliche Technik.
Nee, aber hierzu habe ich jetzt gar keine konkreten Erfahrungswerte.
Quasi, wenn es welche gibt, die das runterspielen.
Ich habe 20 Stunden gearbeitet, ich habe nur zehn gebraucht.
Ja, weiß nicht, kommt das bei dir öfters vor oder, ja wahrscheinlich, sonst würdest du nicht fragen.
Bin ich eigentlich taktisch auch nicht sonderlich geschickt.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Naja, wie gesagt, weil du dann zum Beispiel gefragt wirst, was machst du eigentlich die ganze Zeit.
Stell dir mal vor, du bist für 40 Stunden verplant und du bist auch 40 Stunden am Schaffen
und erzählst immer, ich bin in 20, ich bin in 10 oder 20 Stunden fertig.
Und bist im Zweifelsfall irgendwann noch blöd.
Und dann wird gefragt, was machst du eigentlich die ganze Zeit.
Der Kamelflüsterer ist am Start.
Ja, also das ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen als pauschale Aussage ein bisschen zu extrem.
Aber im Business Enterprise Umfeld ist das eine realistische Sache, da werden Sachen echt gerne aufgebläht.
So nach dem Motto, eigentlich eine Sache von zwei, drei Tagen sich mal intensiv damit beschäftigen.
Das Problem ist, dass du vor lauter Mieten und Kontextswitchen im Kopf kaum zwei, drei Tage am Stück hast.
Da kann es am Ende durchaus mal zwei, drei Wochen dauern.
Das ist leider im Enterprise Umfeld so.
Was auch der Grund ist, warum viele große Unternehmen so wahnsinnig ineffektiv sind.
Weil die unter anderem zu viel mieten und zu viel kleinteilig Sachen an alle Leute verteilen,
sodass du permanent am Umdenken bist zwischen unterschiedlichen Tasks.
Das ist eigentlich das, was so Produktivität killt.
Wenn du an zehn Sachen denken musst.
Und immer mal wieder zwischendrin eine Anruf zu einem anderen Thema oder ein Teams-Message beantworten musst zu einem anderen Thema.
Mieten musst du wieder zu einem anderen Thema.
Irgendwelche Dailies hast du zu einem anderen Thema.
Wie läuft es eigentlich auf der Pay-Per-Fed-Skala?
Ich habe mich heute Morgen gewogen.
Ich habe abgenommen wieder.
Ich hatte ja vorher so ein halbes Kilo wieder zugenommen.
Auf ein bisschen, auf morgen so auf um die 93.
Und heute Morgen habe ich mich noch mit, noch mit, ja mit, also was hatte ich heute Morgen an?
Eine Hose und ein T-Shirt.
Und da hatte ich wieder 92,3.
Also würde ich sagen knapp unter 92 wieder.
Also ich habe jetzt das, was ich zugenommen habe, habe ich wieder abgenommen und noch ein bisschen mehr.
Und einfach durch auf jeden Fall wieder regelmäßig, regelmäßig laufen.
Was ich so die ersten paar Wochen neue Arbeit ein bisschen vernachlässigt habe.
Da hatte ich abends oftmals keinen großartigen Bock, jetzt die eineinhalb Stunden Runde zu machen.
Und vielleicht mal mittags ein bisschen weniger Kekse gefuttert.
Aber ansonsten ist das, es ist wieder, es ist wieder so wie vorher, so wie vor zwei, drei Monaten.
Und vielleicht sogar ein paar Gramm weniger.
Also ich hoffe echt, dass es in nächster Zeit endlich mal unter 90 ist.
Also unter 90 ist ja nach wie vor das Ziel, was ich in nächster Zeit packen will.
Ob ich es packe?
Keine Ahnung.
Fehlt mir das High Performer Cry in the Minds.
Wie groß bist du?
174.
Also ist immer noch Pepo fett.
92 bei 174.
Aber nicht mal so fett wie 107.
107,5 quasi.
Quickmuffs.
Hast du nach der Ausbildung vom Physi eine Weiterbildung gemacht?
Nee.
Warum?
Ich habe ganz normal gearbeitet.
Ist doch Weiterbildung genug.
Du meinst jetzt, ob ich irgendwelche, ob ich juckts?
Äh.
So.
Du meinst jetzt, ob ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, noch, noch Zertifikate und so Zeug gemacht habe?
Nee.
Habe ich nicht.
Das einzige Zertifikat, was ich habe, ist ein CCNA und das noch von der Ausbildung.
Das ist wahrscheinlich schon längst abgelaufen.
Ich glaube, die gehen ja noch drei oder fünf Jahre.
Außerdem juckt das niemand, ob du ein CCNA hast oder nicht.
Jeder, jeder hat ein CCNA und so kompliziert ist es auch nicht.
Und ja, Cisco Netzwerkequipment gehört jetzt auch nicht zum täglichen Aufgabenfeld.
Also es ist relativ irrelevant, ob ich den habe oder nicht.
Ansonsten, nee, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe ein paar Schulungen gemacht.
Also ich habe einen Azure.
Ich habe irgendwo so ein paar Azure Kurse gemacht.
Also Kurse meine ich jetzt nicht irgendwelche Online Sachen, sondern schon mit Microsoft Trainern.
Also offizielle Microsoft Schulungen zu Azure habe ich ein paar gemacht.
Und fällt mir gerade sonst nichts ein.
Bestimmt noch das eine oder andere.
Aber jetzt nichts Fortbildung in Form von, wir machen ein Zertifikat oder irgendwelche höheren Abschlüsse noch oder sonst was.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Ja, das ist immer nicht verkehrt.
Ich meine, guck mal, wir haben hier im Stream so viel gemacht, auch so viel, was nichts mit meiner täglichen Arbeit zu tun hat.
Ja, vom Microcontroller bis Frontend-Programmierung.
Leute, ich habe schon die ein oder anderen Sachen mal gut brauchen können, dass ich mich damit ausgekannt habe.
Letztens konnte ich beispielsweise in einem Meeting auf der Arbeit glänzen,
weil ich wusste, was Client-Side-Hydration ist.
Ihr erinnert euch, Server-Side-Rendering, State einpacken, rüber an Client schicken und da weitermachen.
Also das, was wir mit Zweltkit und sowas schon mal im Stream gemacht haben.
Mega Agile ist das.
Habe ich das, habe ich das erklärt?
Das fanden alle nice.
Wo sie sich dann auch gefragt haben, warum weißt du das als Deluxe-Admin eigentlich?
Tja, weil 5-Head-Twitch-Stream.
Zu viele Twitch-Subscriber für zu hohen IQ.
Hat keiner gefragt.
Wie bist du zum Programmieren gekommen? Hast du dich damit schon vor der Ausbildung...
Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe schon immer gerne programmiert.
Was heißt schon immer?
Nicht so, dass ich auf die Welt gekommen bin und gesagt habe, Alter, lass mich programmieren.
Aber schon lange.
Also auch schon eine ganze Weile vor der Ausbildung.
Also ich habe angefangen mit C-Sharp damals.
Und Python 2.3 oder 2.2.
Oder was auch immer damals aktuell war.
Da hatte ich so ein dickes graues Python-Buch.
Und ich habe dann nach einer Weile angefangen, mich ein bisschen mit C-Sharp.net und Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen auseinanderzusetzen.
Weil ich das...
Ich fand es damals irgendwie spannend, Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen zu machen.
Und ich habe das mit diesem C-Sharp-Buch damals gelernt.
Allerdings nicht mit der 2002er Edition.
Sondern mit der...
Keine Ahnung.
2003 Edition oder so.
Also ich weiß, als ich angefangen habe mit .NET damals, da war .NET 2...
.NET Framework 2 gerade ganz aktuell und neu.
Und super-advanceder Scheiß mit Generics und sowas.
Das dürfte so 2003 irgendwie in dem Dreh rum gewesen sein.
Und Ausbildung habe ich ja erst Jahre später gemacht.
Also das hat mich damals schon interessiert.
Und ich bin auch der Meinung, dass jeder Anwendungsentwickler sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen sollte, wie sieht es aus mit Cloud-Architektur.
Wie sieht es ein bisschen aus mit Linux.
Mit dem Betreiben der Anwendungen, die man gebaut hat.
Ja, mit dem Bereitstellen von Datenbanken, Message-Queues und sonstigen Geschichten.
Und jeder Admin, egal ob Windows oder Linux oder auch jeder Cloud-Architekt und hast du nicht gesehen.
Sollte sich ein bisschen mit Anwendungsentwicklung und Programmieren beschäftigen.
Es ist einfach von unschätzbarem Vorteil, wenn man sich besser, so quasi, wenn man dann auch irgendwelche Meetings hat.
Oder irgendwie sich überlegen muss, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten von der Architektur her.
Dass ich ein bisschen dann reinversetzen kann in die jeweils andere Seite.
Und weiß, okay, was könnte es da für Probleme geben.
Und natürlich muss man auch sagen, Anwendungsentwickler reden auch viel lieber Klartext.
Oder reden auch viel, viel, wie soll man sagen.
Lieber mit jemand, wo sie merken, der hat ein bisschen Ahnung davon, wie es ist, sowas zu programmieren.
Und Admins reden auch lieber mit einem Anwendungsentwickler, der ein bisschen Ahnung davon hat, wie es ist, Linux zu benutzen.
Das ist, das ist, da kommt man sich einfach schneller, schneller näher, ja.
Und kann sich auf irgendwas einigen.
Also es sollten beide Seiten Ahnung haben.
Von der jeweils anderen.
Und wer weiß, wenn man so viel Ahnung hat.
Dass man richtig hat.
Dass man richtig High-IQ alles kann.
Wird man bestimmt irgendwann mal auch zum Full-Stack-Biz-Sack-Win-DevOps.
Falls es sowas gibt.
Aber ist nur noch eine Frage der Zeit.
Wird ja immer mehr in einen Beruf zusammengekleistert.
Und sich dann gefragt, wie.
Wir finden keinen, der unser Frontend, unser Backend und unseren Kubernetes-Cluster administriert.
Was ist da los?
Inklusive Netzwerk-Infrastruktur, Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Und kleinen PCs und noch Support macht nebenbei.
Ne, haben wir noch nicht angeschaut.
Oder doch?
Doch, doch, doch.
Das haben wir schon angeschaut.
Bin Ende des Jahres für einen Monat von der Berufsschule aus in Vancouver.
Ist das in Kanada?
Ich bin geografisch nicht so fit.
Ich glaube, das ist in Kanada, ja.
Oder Australien.
Ne, aus Kanada, ja.
Was glaubst du wäre etwas, was ich als Wunsch sagen sollte, dass ich lernen möchte?
Moment, warum bist du von der Berufsschule in Vancouver?
Was ist das für eine Berufsschule?
Haben die Schüler Austausch oder wie?
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Interessant.
Aber gut.
Warum nicht?
Ja.
Na ja, Enterprise-Hardware ist ein sehr dehnbarer Begriff.
Das kann alles sein.
Da setzen sie dich im Zweifelsfall zum Kobold-Programmieren von einem IBM-Host.
Das würde ich so wahrscheinlich nicht sagen.
Aber DevOps-Zeugs ist schon mal nicht verkehrt.
Wobei DevOps-Zeug ja auch alle so nichts bedeuten kann.
Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Idee.
So nichts bedeuten kann.
Wollte einen VM-Champ-as-a-Service bauen, der automatisch die neueste Version installiert und im Terminal Notifications sendet, wenn du...
Was hat das denn mit dem VM-Champ zu tun?
Den Zusammenhang der Software und ob ich streame, erkenne ich jetzt nicht.
Aber zu erkennen, ob jemand streamt, ist über die Twitch-API recht einfach.
Beziehungsweise generell über den Browser einfach die Channel-Seite abrufen.
Easy rauszubekommen.
Okay.
Ja dann.
GLHF.
Muss ich übrigens gerade mal was gucken.
VM-Champ.
Ob es da irgendwelche Issues oder sonst was gibt.
Oh.
No Bash-Completion.
Ach, tatsächlich.
Das habe ich gesehen.
Der Fips hat das aufgemacht.
Er ist auch gerade im Chat.
Deshalb habe ich gesehen, dass es keine Bash-Completion gibt.
Ich war bisher zu faul, Bash-Completion einzubauen, weil ich nicht weiß, wie Bash-Completion funktioniert.
ZSH-Completion konnte ich einfach copy-pasten und ein bisschen anpassen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie so eine Bash-Completion aussehen muss.
Ja, warum nicht.
Ein IT-Konzept kann ja alles sein.
Ich mache SSDs anstatt HDDs in die Desktop-PCs.
Das kann auch ein IT-Konzept sein.
Aber warum nicht?
Ich persönlich hätte jetzt wenig Bock, längere Zeit nach Kanada zu gehen.
Aber sicherlich Geschmackssache.
Kannst du mal in eine Arch-VM starten?
Mit dem VM-Champ hatte letzte Woche eine Kernel-Panic.
Okay, weil du es bist.
Kann man machen.
Restart Docker.
Moment, Docker?
Hä, was mache ich denn?
Docker brauchen wir doch überhaupt nicht.
Ne, kann ich machen.
Okay, VM-Champ.
Run.
Minus Minus OS.
Arch.
Memory.
2G.
Disk.
8G.
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Das müsste gehen.
Du musst Arch-Dealings ein bisschen mehr RAM geben, dass das ordentlich booten kann.
Ich glaube, 128 oder was ich als Default eingestellt habe, ist ein bisschen wenig.
Das dürfte das Problem sein.
Scheint zu starten.
Guck.
Na, auf.
Wie wäre es mal mit Connecten hier?
Nee, funktioniert.
Guck.
Das liegt am RAM.
Ja, wenn es nicht geht, liegt es zu höchstwahrscheinlich.
Arch-Dealings bootet auch so langsam, dass das ab Anfang nicht mehr funktioniert.
Da musst du dich danach dann nochmal per SSH connecten.
Dann funktioniert es.
Werden wir gleich sehen.
Dass, wenn eine Default-Bridge erstellt werden muss, dass die VM danach nicht ins Internet
kommt.
Echt jetzt?
Keine Ahnung.
So ein Problem hatte ich nicht.
VM-Champ.
SSH.
Ja, guck.
Das ist noch gar nicht gebootet.
Arch Linux dauert eine ganze Weile, bis das gestartet ist.
Okay, jetzt ist es da.
Guck mal.
Der SSH läuft immer noch.
Kann das sein, dass Arch Linux standardmäßig gar kein SSH mitbringt?
Ich hab mich schon mal so blöd gefragt.
Könnte das vielleicht sein?
Weil eine Netzwerkadresse haben wir.
Doch geht.
Geht.
Braucht einfach nur viel zu lang.
Nee, nee, ist schon dabei.
Ist schon dabei.
das Cloud-Image. Hätte mich nämlich sehr gewundert,
wenn beim Cloud-Image, beziehungsweise
bei diesem, ja, beim VM-Image
kein SSH dabei gewesen wäre. Doch, doch, ist dabei.
Klappt auch. Ist bloß
ein bisschen lahm beim Booten.
Oh, alles wieder weg.
Ja, also brauchst du ein bisschen mehr RAM, dann geht's
auch. Ja, aber
ist auch gemacht. Gut ist.
Ich bin gerade am überlegen,
was wir als nächstes, was wir
als nächstes machen können. Wie gesagt,
ich muss mir noch den, noch,
wir müssen uns noch KDE fertig angucken
und den
Mint-Mate-Desktop. Aber das ist ja
nix langfristiges.
Ich überlege gerade, was wir als nächstes,
was wir uns mal als nächstes angucken können.
Wenn ich wieder ein bisschen mehr Bock habe auf
Linux basteln, auf
privat, ja, muss ich ja sagen,
dadurch, dass ich jetzt einen neuen Job habe und mich da auch mit
vielen Sachen beschäftigen muss, ist so meine
Aufnahmekapazität, so was neue Sachen
angeht, gerade ein bisschen begrenzt.
Einfach eine Buchhaltungssoftware
entwickeln, welche im Browser aufrufbar
ist. Easy. Ja, macht
man als Ein-Mann-Projekt. Nebenbei, gar
kein Problem.
SAP 2.0 als
Web-Assembly-Anwendung
als Ein-Mann-Entwicklungsprojekt.
Ja, genau das.
Easy. Just
Buchhaltungssoftware-Vorhead.
Neowim. Tatsächlich,
das sollten wir uns echt mal langsam angucken.
Da hätte ich auch irgendwie
Bock drauf, mal ein Neowim zu customizen,
aber so komplett customizen mit
Language-Server und dem ganzen Kram.
Wir könnten alternativ auch
NVChat verwenden.
Nein, from scratch.
From scratch.
NVChat.
Warum hat eigentlich NVChat
nicht irgendwie ein ordentliches
Logo, irgendeine Art und Weise?
Ja, from scratch,
ja, machen wir auch. Ich glaube auch nicht.
Ich mochte so WIM-Distributionen
noch nie, die ganze tausend Sachen
da immer gebundelt haben.
Warenwirtschaft,
Schem, genau darauf hat die Welt
gewartet. Vor allem, weil meine Software
ja dafür bekannt ist,
fertig zu werden und
lange maintained zu werden und sowas.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal an.
Der Fiat-Champ auf GitHub, ne?
14 offene Issues.
Okay, die Hälfte davon ist nicht
umsetzbar oder nicht reproduzierbar.
Aber ich hab
aktuell keinen Bock daran weiterzubauen,
weil es bei mir einfach...
funktioniert.
Ja, Multiple Cars, dafür gibt es sogar hier schon
ein Pull-Request.
Ja, hier gibt es ein Pull-Request für Multiple Cars.
Aber Luxus...
Luxus-Probleme.
Der hat mehr als ein Fiat-Auto.
Und ich glaube, was aktuell
auch nicht geht,
ist, dass du
einen Fiat und einen Jeep
mit dem Add-On gleichzeitig
abfragst.
Es geht nur ein Hersteller gleichzeitig.
Was kann man alles auf GitHub machen?
Das sprengt jetzt den Rahmen,
mir im Stream was zu zeigen,
zumal ich dir nichts mal zeigen kann,
weil ich bin nicht mal eingeloggt.
Du kannst auf GitHub mit anderen Leuten
zusammen an Software arbeiten
und deine Software der Welt
zugänglich machen.
Es gibt übrigens einen Bug
bei der neuesten Home Assistant-Version,
die ich noch nicht habe, weil ich noch nicht
upgradet habe. Das heißt, ich muss wahrscheinlich
wirklich an den Fiat-Champ mal ran,
in nächster Zeit wieder.
Ja,
ja,
so ist das halt.
Wenn ich irgendwas release,
entweder wird das nie fertig
und wird das gar nicht released, und wenn ich es release,
muss ich es weiter maintainen und habe dann irgendwie
nach ein paar Monaten keinen Bock mehr.
Ich habe, was Game-Entwicklung
angeht, überhaupt keinen Plan.
Der steht hier.
Den gibt es noch. Der bleibt auch da,
für Emo-Zeug zu spielen.
Ja, ja.
Der steht hier und der bleibt auch.
Der kommt auch nicht weg.
Habt ihr Empfehlungen,
für Seiten, die Logos erstellen?
Ähm, tatsächlich, ja, habe ich.
Und die habe ich auch nur verwendet,
weil ich dort eh schon einen Account habe.
Guck mal den hier.
Der Namecheap-Logo-Maker.
Das ist, das ist mega easy hier.
Äh, cute Chat-App.
Oh, continue.
Tschu, tschu, hallo.
Ja, choose the style.
Das ist exzellent, cute.
Ah.
Wunderbar.
Continue.
Icons.
Chat.
Ah.
Continue.
Guck mal, baut das hier ein Logo.
Das ist, das ist tatsächlich ganz, ganz nice, sowas.
Guck mal, das, ohne Mist.
Das hier wäre doch wirklich ein ganz cooles Logo, oder?
Cute Chat und dann so ein Ding.
Wobei, der, der richtige cute Chat bräuchte ja.
Ayaya, ayaya.
So was.
Sven, danke schön für den Sub.
Hab morgen Bewerbungsgespräch für Schule über IT-Helptest und so weiter.
Was?
Bewerbungsgespräch für Schule über IT.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ähm.
Du willst dich als Admin bei einer Schule bewerben?
Oder du willst dich als Schüler bei einer,
da musst du ein bisschen mehr erklären,
den Satz verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Wie, wo, was?
Wie, wie?
Wie?
sich da. Wie gesagt,
Spieleentwicklung, keine Ahnung.
Ne, hab ich auch keinen Bock.
Dein Lieblingsspiel?
Das kann ich so pauschal nicht sagen.
Ich kann dir, okay, ich sag dir das
erste, was mir ins Gedächtnis kommt,
beziehungsweise das Spiel, was,
wobei das auch nicht stimmt, aber zumindest
eines der Spiele, die
mit den bleibendsten Eindruck bei mir
hinterlassen haben, über all die
Jahre, ist Half-Life.
Half-Life 1.
Ähm, und was
ich am längsten gespielt habe und am
intensivsten online gespielt habe, ist
Dark Age of Camelot als MMO.
Aber es gibt noch
sehr viele andere Games, wo ich
sagen würde, die sind ganz vorne
mit dabei.
Es gibt auch Super Nintendo Spiele,
wo ich sagen würde, die gehören mit
zu den besten Games aller Zeiten.
Zum Beispiel Chrono Trigger, falls
ihr das nicht gespielt habt und so ein bisschen auf
JRPGs steht.
Mega nice das Game.
Ich mein, es ist halt ein
16-Bit-Spiel. Viele denken
sich's an heute so nach dem Motto, äh,
16-Bit. Wobei ich sag, Gothic
war auch ein mega nice Game, ja.
Das erste Far Cry, es gab
so, es gibt mega viele geile Spiele.
Aber, ähm,
also das erste, was mir halt so
bauchgefühlmäßig einfällt, ist
Half-Life 1.
Ich kann's übrigens
nicht oft genug sagen.
Ich finde, dass 16-Bit-Spiele, gerade
Super Nintendo Spiele, echt
gut gealtert sind. Guckt euch
mal PS1
möchte gern PS1
3D-Spiele an,
versus schöne 16-Bit-Super-Nintendo-Spiele.
Und ich
nehme halt 16,
äh, gibt's die hier
nicht irgendwo? Tja, keine Ahnung.
Also, ihr müsst einfach,
ich finde halt, dass 16-Bit-Spiele, ja,
wenn man sich das hier anguckt, ich finde,
die sind mega gut gealtert.
Muss das ja ungefähr in der Auflösung
spielen.
Und
ich, ich weiß
nicht, ich nehme
so 16-Bit-Character
so Emotionen mehr ab,
als so den ersten 3D-Models.
Also, falls jemand von euch
noch nicht Chrono Trigger gespielt hat, solltet ihr
unbedingt machen. Das ist eines der besten
so JRPGs
der Super Nintendo Ära und
meiner Meinung nach mit das Beste,
was eigentlich je in diesem Genre
produziert wurde.
Haben ihn Schüler und muss mich
bewerben.
Ähm, um Schule
weiterzumachen. Ja, aber wo musst du dich
bewerben?
Weil, du musst dich von der Schule aus
für so eine Art Praktikum bewerben.
Bei irgendeinem
Betrieb oder sowas.
Ja, okay, also als was bewirbst du dich
denn überhaupt? Als Praktikant
oder was? Als Praktikant
oder, oder, also ich gehe mal davon aus,
Praktikant, ganz ehrlich, Bewerbungsgespräche
als Praktikant.
Äh, du solltest
dich interessieren dafür, ja.
Du kannst durchaus auch ein paar
Fragen zur Firma stellen, warum
nicht? Ich glaube, am wichtigsten
als eine Stelle am Praktikant
ist, dass man irgendwie Interesse an dem
an dem Beruf zeigt,
ja.
Ansonsten, von einem Praktikant
erwartet keiner, dass er super krasse
Vorkenntnisse hat. Ehrlich gesagt, erwartet
man beim Praktikant eigentlich
überhaupt nichts an Vorkenntnissen.
Wenn du irgendwas hast,
kannst du das denen ruhig aufs
Brot schmieren. Ich weiß ja nicht, in welchem
wie du dich auskennst.
Ansonsten, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie man sich als Praktikant gescheit bewirbt.
Chat, habt ihr irgendwelche
Tipps?
Ich habe da wenig Ahnung.
Wann installierst du
eigentlich wieder eine cute
Ubuntu VM? Oh, nee.
Die habe ich doch eh nie benutzt.
Nee, kein Stream.
Bei der Ausbildung zum Physi hast du da viel
Hardware beim PC dran gearbeitet? Ja.
Wobei nicht wirklich Hardware
beim PC, das kann man so nicht sagen.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte ich da
viel Festplatten eingebaut oder irgendwelche
Desktop-PCs aufgebaut. Aber ja,
ich habe in der Ausbildung tatsächlich sehr viel
mit Hardware gemacht. Allerdings mit
Enterprise Business Server Hardware.
Ich war täglich
in unterschiedlichsten Rechenzentren
in Frankfurt unterwegs. Ich habe Server
eingebaut, ich habe Server verkabelt, ich habe
im Zweifelsfall, wenn meine Netzteile, Lüfter
kaputt waren, neue bestellt,
neue zuschicken lassen, rübergetragen,
eingebaut,
Storage-Sachen angeschlossen
und solche Geschichten. Also
aus der Zeit, also
zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt
konnte ich dir sagen,
wenn ich morgens durch dunkle
Rechenzentren gelaufen bin, die Story habe ich
euch ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
ich bin morgens immer durch die Rechenzentren
bei uns gelaufen und habe geguckt,
ob alles in Ordnung ist. Ich habe das sogar
freiwillig gemacht, weil ich meistens der Erste war
oder einer der Ersten, die auf der
Arbeit gewesen sind
und
also nichts mit
PC-Hardware. Na ja, PC-Hardware und
Server-Hardware ist doch jetzt nicht so
du kannst, du
das macht doch keinen Unterschied.
Na klar, die Form ist
ein bisschen anders, aber ansonsten
so und ich
war immer als erstes da und da habe ich
freiwillig gesagt, ich mache einfach Rundgang
in jedem
unserer Rechenzentren. Das klingt jetzt mehr als
es waren drei Stück, ja.
Eins im Keller,
noch eins im Keller
und eins im
achten Stock oder sowas.
So und
ich konnte euch damals
sagen, ich bin ja immer
im Dunklen, genau das ist das, was ich
sagen wollte, ich bin ja immer im Dunklen durch die Rechenzentren
gelaufen morgens. Also ich
habe nie die Lichter angemacht da drinnen,
weil ich finde, das hat irgendwie so eine nette Stimmung gehabt
im dunklen Rechenzentrum rumzulaufen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das gegen
jegliche Arbeitsschutzvorschriften gewesen
oder sowas, da musstest du wahrscheinlich, durftest
du nur bei Licht laufen und sowas.
Wobei ich
habe da eine Sache gelernt beim Provider
noch. Manchmal sind so
Arbeitsschutzbestimmungen
und Vorgaben gar nicht so schlecht,
weil ich war mal dabei, da ist
einem ein DL380, vollbeladener
HP DL380
Server aus
so Tragehöhe auf den Fuß gefallen.
Das sind solche
Kisten.
Ja, sowas hier.
So ein Ding.
Und wenn dir so ein Ding
vollbeladen, so aus normaler Höhe,
wo du es trägst, runter auf den
Fuß fällt und du hast keine Sicherheitsschuhe an,
Leute, ich kann euch sagen,
dem sein Fuß, der ist dran gewesen noch
und das ist auch wieder geheilt, aber der konnte
zwei Wochen nicht laufen.
Ich meine, was wird so ein Ding?
Chat, was meint ihr? Ich weiß es jetzt wirklich nicht aus dem Kopf genau.
Was wird so ein Ding vollbeladen
wiegen?
30 Kilo? Die Alten hatten
ja auch noch Festplatten, das hier sind ja noch
alles SSDs. Muss man eher Gen 5
oder so gucken. Ja, so ein Ding.
Oder Gen 6.
So ein Ding hier war das.
Genau so ein Teil ist dem da auf den
Fuß gefallen.
30 Kilo? Ich weiß nicht, würde ich
jetzt mal raten.
Naja, zumindest
ich bin immer im Dunkeln
morgens durchs Rechenzentrum gelaufen
und ich konnte euch damals sagen,
ist jetzt wirklich also ungelogen, ja,
ich konnte euch damals sagen, wenn ich durchs, also ich
hätte euch sagen können, hätten wir uns damals schon
gekannt,
welche LED
nicht so leuchtet
wie gewöhnlich.
Und ich meine damit nicht nur Warn-LEDs
wie Lüfter ist kaputt auf Orange.
Ja, also ich war da so oft
morgens, ich hab mir das alles genau angeguckt.
Ich konnte euch wirklich sagen, wenn irgendwie
an der Stelle ein neues System eingebaut wurde,
hab ich sofort gesehen, da steht irgendwas anderes drin.
Und die Rechenzentren waren jetzt nicht mega
groß, aber auch nicht total klein.
Also, die
waren so, ja, mittel,
also, das waren,
also das Größte morgens, wo ich durch
bin, das war, lass mal überlegen,
ich überlege gerade, wie viele, wie viele Racks
das waren, so 40 oder
so, naja, 50, mit der
anderen, so 50, 50 Racks
vielleicht.
Das war das Größte, wo ich morgens durch bin.
Die anderen zwei waren kleiner, das andere hatte
irgendwie 20, 30
Racks und das andere war mini,
das hatte drei Stück oder so.
Und ich konnte euch wirklich sagen, bei dem Kurs,
wo irgendwelche Lampen unterschiedlich
sind, vom, zum Tag vorher.
Also, so gut kannte ich
mich bei uns im Rechenzentrum aus.
Und ich konnte euch
auch sagen, ob es normal war,
dass die Lüfter in dieser Ecke so laut
waren oder nicht, ja,
also, da wusste,
da wusste ich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich, die wusste ich
wirklich gut über unsere Infrastruktur Bescheid.
Das war halt noch Turnschuhatmen.
Ich war damals auch noch dünner,
also, noch dünner als, als
äh,
vielleicht ein bisschen dünner
als jetzt. Ich hab ja ordentlich abgenommen.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen dünner als jetzt,
weil da Felix und ich, wir waren die
einzigen zwei, die sie immer in die engen Technikräume
in den Etagenverteilern
geschickt haben, weil wir die einzigen zwei
waren, die noch jung
genug und dünn genug waren,
um uns an allen Switchen und
Kabeln vorbei zu krabbeln,
mit eingezogenem Bauch, ohne
dass wir die halben Kabel
aus der Patchwand rausreißen.
Sehr agil.
Ja, ans Trinken erinnern.
Pogu, mach ich.
Ja, ist auch so. Was heißt unfairer
Vergleich? Es ging nicht darum,
das irgendwie fair oder unfair zu machen, sondern
einfach nur, dass es eben so ist,
dass 16-Bit-2D-Grafik
für mich viel besser gealtert ist
und das würdest du jetzt ja auch so
bestätigen, ja, wie
die ersten 3D-Games oder
wie lange Zeit 3D-Games.
Ich mein ernsthaft, wir müssen uns nicht
PS1-3D-Grafik angucken.
Wir können uns auch durchaus 3D-Grafik
angucken zu Zeiten von Half-Life 1
oder sowas. Guckt euch heute mal
Half-Life 1 an. Das sieht
ugly as fuck aus. Oder guckt euch
das erste Unreal an. Man war
von Unreal 1
damals zwar extrem
begeistert und ich finde ganz ehrlich,
gerade so die Außenlevel
und so, die kann man sich heute
tatsächlich auch noch halbwegs angucken.
Aber die 3D-Models
und sowas, das ist schon aus heutiger Sicht
also sehr
low-res quasi.
Ziemlich, ziemlich. Ich mein, guckt euch
das mal an. Sowas kannst du heute
keinem mehr als 3D-Model
verkaufen. Ja, du warst damals
ultra beeindruckt von Unreal 1.
Wirklich gut gealtert ist es auch nicht.
Ich würde sagen, wirklich
annehmbar gealtert
sind 3D-Spiele erst so
ab
Wii
und
ein bisschen Gamecube, ein bisschen
Wii und erst ab
Xbox 360 so richtig, dann
ansonsten
davor
sieht vieles schon echt abartig
aus. Das einzig
Gute, es gibt, es gibt ein paar
Ausnahmen, genau, wollte ich auch
gerade sagen, es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen. Zum Beispiel
Wind Waker, also jetzt vom
Gamecube, ist mega gut gealtert durch den
Look. Sachen wie Warcraft 3
sind auch mega gut gealtert durch den Look.
Ich finde auch, dass so Sachen wie
Diablo 2 ganz gut gealtert sind
oder
gut, Diablo 2 ist ja
ja, nicht wirklich
3D.
Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen, die gut
gealtert sind, was aber auch hauptsächlich
am Style der Games liegt.
Spiele, die zu ihrer
Release-Zeit möglichst realistisch sein
wollten, sind meistens relativ schlecht gealtert.
Ich meine, ich war sehr
beeindruckt vom ersten Far Cry
und ich denke mal, Far Cry 1
ist tatsächlich eines der Games,
die noch ganz
passabel gealtert sind
für ihr,
ja, für ihr Release-Datum.
Aber trotzdem, an vielen Stellen
denke ich, wird man auch heute
denken, wenn man sich, ich meine, das sieht vollkommen
in Ordnung aus, ja, aber an vielen
Stellen wird man sich auch angucken, gerade die Models
und sowas, wenn man sich Far Cry 1 anguckt, wird man sich
auch denken, na,
man merkt ihm das
Alter an und das ist halt 2004. Das ist
so die Zeit, ab der 3D-Spiele,
die auf Realismus gemacht haben,
halbwegs spielbar sind heute noch.
Crysis 1
ist schon, ist neuer und
sieht gut aus. Und Sachen davor
müssen halt wirklich den passenden, den passenden
Style haben.
Half-Life 2 ist auch richtig, richtig gut
gealtert, ja, das stimmt. Aber
ansonsten muss ich sagen,
gerade aus den 3D-Anfangsjahren
ist vieles nicht wirklich gut gealtert.
Und ich, wie gesagt,
also, ich mag
16-Bit-Pixel-Grafik
einfach. Also ich würde sagen, von
von so RPGs
dürfte auf dem Super Nintendo
Chrono Trigger und Final Fantasy,
6, wirklich eines der hübschesten Games
gewesen sein. So, so JRPG-mäßig.
Die sind
beide wirklich pogu.
Also sowohl vom Game her, als
auch von der Optik. Also viel mehr,
viel mehr konntest du aus dem Super Nintendo nicht, nicht rausholen.
Es gab dann irgendwann, gab
es noch, äh,
Tales of Phantasia, das kam
aber, glaube ich, in Europa nie raus.
Das hatte so nen, so nen Spezialchip
drauf, dass sie sogar nen Intro,
nen Intro-Song, so nen Anime
Intro-Song in dem, in nem
Super Nintendo-Spiel einbauen konnten. Das hat man
bis zur damaligen Zeit auch nicht gesehen.
Ja.
Na, Morrowind, finde ich, ist
nicht wirklich gut gealtert. Also,
mit Mods vielleicht, aber im Original
ich weiß nicht.
Es ist schon, äh,
semi-gut gealtert
vielleicht.
Oblivion geht dann schon voll klar, ja.
Hatte die EMC-Hardware
in deinem alten Job? Ja, hatten wir.
Hatten wir.
Ja, ich hab, ich hab viele
Tickets aufgemacht, damals
bei IBM und hab gesagt, hier, wir brauchen
neues Netzteil, neuen Lüfter, neue Festplatte,
was auch immer. Und dann braucht man bei IBM,
Leute, wenn ihr jemals bei IBM ein Ticket
aufmacht, ganz wichtig, denkt dran,
die Frunummer!
Ohne Frunummer
geht nix.
Das ist so die, die
Inventarnummer bei IBM.
Wenn ihr keine
Frunummer habt,
IBM-Fru, genau,
die steht, die steht da hier irgendwie drauf.
Gibt's bei IBM nix. Frunummer
ist das Allerwichtigste.
Moin, Christian.
Ja, Fisis machen sehr viele verschiedene Sachen.
Mainzer Landstraße
155?
Äh,
ne,
ich glaube nicht.
Ne.
Aber auf jeden Fall nicht weit weg von der Mainzer Landstraße.
Sind Hochverf...
Oh, das ist, das ist, das ist eine interessante Frage.
Sind Hochverfassungs...
...verfügbare Server viel komplexer
als normale Server im Webhosting?
Also, Server sind nicht
das, was Hochver...
Kleierstraße war ich auch schon. In der Kleierstraße war ich drin,
aber da bin ich... Kleierstraße hatte ich...
Das ist größer gewesen, in der Kleierstraße
als Rechenzentrum. Aber das ist nicht
Teil dieser drei Rechenzentren, die ich meine,
wo ich täglich einen Rundgang gemacht hab.
Kleierstraße war ich auch öfters drin und, und,
ähm...
In der Kleierstraße haben wir, die, haben wir
die Decke unseres Storages
verkratzt, weil der, weil
der Aufzug zu klein war.
Und die
Leute, die das
gefahren haben, trotz Quietschen
das Storage aus dem Fahrstuhl rausgepresst
haben. Da ist dann auch das Plastik
abgesplittert oben vom Storage und sowas.
Ja, ja. Aber gut.
Ich meine, das Storage hat's überlebt, auch mit
verkratztem Deckel. Ja, also,
es sind ja meistens nicht die Server,
die hochverfügbar sind, sondern die Anwendungen
auf dem, die du,
die du auf dem Server laufen lässt.
Die
musst du hochverfügbar machen.
Und, ja, in der Regel kann man
sagen, sind hochverfügbare Services
deutlich komplexer als
ein Single,
Single Node Service.
Und wenn du's
nicht gescheit machst und wenn du nicht aufpasst,
kann es sogar sein,
dass du durch die, durch die
Hochverfügbarkeit weniger Verfügbarkeit
hättest als bei einem Single Node
ähm, System.
Weil wenn du's nicht gescheit machst und
du quasi Ausfälle hast,
durch deine Hochverfügbarkeitskonstruktion,
ist es natürlich auch doof. Du musst es gescheit machen.
Du musst wissen, was du machst.
Was in der Regel heißt, bei einem
Cluster eigentlich immer drei Nodes.
Zwei Nodes machen
nur Probleme bei Hochverfügbarkeit.
Das kann ich euch aus eigener Erfahrung sagen.
Wisst ihr, was das größte
Problem ist, wenn du nicht drei Cluster Nodes
hast, die ordentlich netzwerktechnisch
angebunden sind? Chat.
Wer ist vom Fach und, äh, oder macht,
lernt Physi oder sonst was. Was ist das
größte Problem, wenn du,
wenn du nen Cluster baust mit nur zwei Nodes?
Oder der, der, der häufigste
Fehler, den du hast. Split Brain.
Genau. Ja.
So sieht's aus.
Das heißt,
ja, ihr, ihr geht alle
in die gleiche Richtung, Chat. Ich bin, ich bin
zufrieden mit euch.
Five Header Chat.
Ähm, ja, also es geht alles,
es geht alles in die richtige Richtung.
Das Problem ist, wenn du nen zwei
Node Cluster hast,
und es ruckelt netzwerktechnisch
irgendwas, oder
es ist, äh, davor irgendwas kaputt,
wie auch immer, ja, dass
dann beide Knoten
relativ schnell denken, der andere
ist kaputt und sie müssen jetzt Master sein.
Was dann dazu führt, dass wenn du
beispielsweise IPs hast, die schwenken,
von einem auf den anderen Node, dass du
auf einmal zwei Master-Knoten
hast, die beide denken, wir
sind aktiv, weil der andere ja weg ist.
Und solche Geschichten.
Also, das, das führt,
öfter als man denkt, zu Problemen, das heißt,
wenn man nen Cluster macht, dann müssen es
drei Nodes sein, und
die ganzen müssen netz-, die müssen
netzwerktechnisch auch so miteinander verbunden sein,
dass ein Netzwerk-Ruckler
in, an irgendeiner Stelle nicht
dazu führt, dass die Nodes sich alle auf einmal nicht mehr
untereinander sehen. Also am besten
auch irgendeine extra Interconnect-Verbindung
oder sonstige Geschichten.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Also Services, also Cluster Services
aufzubauen, ist viel,
viel komplexer als ein Single Node,
Betrieb.
Und schlecht gemacht
ist ein High Availability
Cluster auch oftmals
weniger verfügbar als
ne fette Single Node Kiste. Also da braucht man
wirklich Leute, die wissen, was sie machen
und mit dem nötigen Fingerspitzen-
gefühl da rangehen.
Oder man kauft sich das als
Service fix und fertig und bezahlt Geld dafür.
Kannst du sowas auf dem Arm tragen, klar.
Felix und ich,
wir haben damals, wir haben ganze, ganze
Playcenter und
30.000 Euro teure
Loadbalancer auf dem Bollerwagen
durch Frankfurt gefahren.
Du musst dich mal überlegen.
Wir hatten so einen komischen RZ-Bollerwagen
und hatten da irgendwie 20, 30.000
Euro teure Loadbalancer gestapelt,
die immer teilweise fast runtergerutscht
sind und sowas. Warum die uns mit damals
uff, ey, keine Ahnung.
Wenn so ein Ding runtergefallen wäre,
wäre halt einfach mal ein Auto,
wie ein Auto vernichtet quasi.
So extrem war es nicht, dass ich die
Blinkrate morgens von einem Server
wusste, aber
also wenn es ganz ausgefallen
war, schon, so nach dem Motto
normalerweise blinkt es regelmäßig und jetzt blinkt es
irgendwie gar nicht mehr oder ganz an,
schon, aber so den Intervall
der Blinkrate, das hätte ich dir nicht
sagen können. Ja, das war
Turnschuh-Monitoring noch.
Könntest du mir sagen, wenn ich dir mein Problem
bei meinem Notebook sagen würde, was die Ursachen
Ne, Remote zu diagnostizieren
ist meistens nicht gescheit möglich.
Ich meine, du kannst mal in Chat
schreiben, vielleicht sind die Leute hier so
high IQ, was
wir ja wissen, dass sie sind,
ob die irgendeine Idee dazu haben, aber ich fürchte
Remote-Diagnose kannst du knicken.
Das stimmt, Warcraft 3 ist gut gealtert.
Das erste Anno,
die sind auch ganz brauchbar gealtert.
Ich habe eine NVMe SSD drin als
Main
Platte.
Das klingt ganz nach IBM.
Das ist wirklich IBM, also
die IBM-Website ist auch so eklig,
IBM
Guckt euch mal diese
Webseiten an.
Alter, boah.
Die IBM-Websiten,
man, das ist so abartig.
Und das ist schon die bisschen neuere,
die alten waren noch schlimmer.
Was ist das für eine bescheuere Frage?
Das ist doch G-Bait, oder?
Wie wäre es
mit einem CSGO-Kisten-Stream
wie bei Monte? Kannst du dir die Schlüssel steuerlich
absetzen lassen? Alter, ich mache weder
CSGO, noch mache ich irgendwelche Glücksspiel-
Streams. Und ob ich die Sachen steuerlich absetzen
kann oder nicht, ich würde ja
tatsächlich sogar unterm Strich noch Minus machen,
weil ich, ich habe doch nicht mal
was von.
Ja, die
Logik verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz an dem Satz.
Aber das ist, das ist eindeutig,
eindeutig G-Bait-Einsatz.
Aber trotzdem.
Vor allem,
stellt euch mal vor,
Max, Max als Casino-
Streamer oder Skin-Glücksspiel-Streamer,
Alter, nee, im Leben nicht.
Oh, ich bin müde, Leute.
Gleich ist,
gleich ist
Bad-Get-Time
angesagt.
Welche Größe vom, vom, ähm,
Moment.
Meinst du das Steam-Deck
oder das Stream-Deck?
Du meinst das
Stream-Deck wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe kein Stream-Deck.
Kein Stream-Deck.
Ich habe, ich habe
ein selbst, ich habe ein selbstgebautes,
ich habe ein selbstgebautes Stream-Deck.
Selbstgebautes Stream-Deck.
Was ich auch vor Jahren mal gebaut habe
und da nie wieder was dran geändert habe, aber es funktioniert
halt. Es geht halt einfach.
Hast du eigentlich schon mal eine Call of Duty
Tierlist gemacht? Ja.
Habe ich.
Ja, habe ich.
Ziemlich sicher habe ich das schon gemacht.
Bin ich jetzt aber
spontan zu unkreativ für.
Aber ihr kennt mich, wahrscheinlich ist COD 4
und Black Ops 1 ganz oben.
Stream-Deck, Champ,
Rewrite in Rust.
Im Leben, also die Software ist ja nicht
mal ansatzweise fertig, aber in Rust
rewriten will ich mich irgendwie
besonders quälen.
Vim only Rust, genau.
Tschüssi Po, Dankeschön für den Sub.
21 Monate, das ist ja
extremely poggers.
Das war jetzt auch ein bisschen verspätet,
oder?
Oder kann das sein, dass der gar keine Subscribtions
mehr anzeigt?
Danke für den Sub.
Der zeigt keine Subscribtions mehr an.
Wie hast du dein Stream-Deck
entwickelt? Nein, das ist ja kein Stream-Deck.
Das ist ja ein Web Interface
mit dem man
Bilder
overlayen kann
und paar Sounds abspielen kann.
Das ist glaube ich
noch eine .NET Framework
4.8 Anwendung
mit
Vue.js 1 oder sowas.
Das ist uralt.
Das ist schon 5 Jahre alt oder so.
Guck mal, eine der ersten Bilder war noch
die alte Katz.
Es läuft, ja. Und es läuft,
es hat auch die Migration auf Windows 10 und
Windows 11 ohne Probleme überstanden.
Und ich glaube man musste gar nichts
dafür anpassen, es ging einfach.
It just works.
Gutschi Roll.
Welche Library benutzt
du für das Overlay?
Also,
wenn ich mich recht
entsinne.
Ist das hier eine Vue.js
Anwendung?
Ja, sieht sehr nach Vue.js aus, ne?
Okay, alles klar.
Vue.js
Mit Signal A
als Messaging.
Sieht man da nicht Vue.js?
Das ist die Vue.js Version
bis 2018.
Oh, schon eine Vue.js 2 Anwendung, immerhin.
Also das Frontend ist Vue.js 2.
Das Backend ist
ASP.NET Core.
Schon.
Allerdings, es ist eine
.NET Framework 4.8 Anwendung.
Und das Overlay
Fenster, was man hier jetzt nicht sieht,
also sprich
das, was hier diese Overlays,
man sieht es ja so ein bisschen,
wenn man sich mal
anschauen kann.
Das ist eine WPF Anwendung.
Man sieht es hier teilweise noch.
Guckt mal hier unten hin.
Guckt mal hier unten hin, wenn ich es minimiere.
Seht ihr das?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das...
Ja doch, manchmal erkennt man es unten ein bisschen, ne?
Beim Fenster minimieren sieht man manchmal noch
unten ganz kurz das Ding
reinblitzen.
Dymo Connect, ja übelste Dreckssoftware.
Signal A,
das ist quasi sowas wie
Websockets.
Nur
Microsoft Style Websockets.
Ja.
Gibt es für den Dymo
auch. Das Problem ist,
ich brauche ja irgendwas, um Labels zu designen
und Labels zu machen. Da ist die Software
ganz okay für. Aber an sich
ist es ziemlicher Müll.
Oh, ich bin müde, es gibt es ja gar nicht.
Es ist wirklich
sleepgegleicher angesagt.
Noch 10 Minuten.
Die taugen allerdings.
Der Label Champ war der beste
Label Designer, Webinterface
basiert, oder? Der Label Champ
war einfach meilenweit voraus.
Leider
ist der Label Champ nie fertig geworden.
Tom, du bist der
Top-Geschenkegeber.
Was auch immer
uns Twitch damit sagen möchte.
Aber, POG.
Hahaha.
Lull.
Ist das schlecht.
Der Label Champ war viel
advancer, Leute.
Kennt überhaupt noch einer den Label Champ?
Der Label Champ war richtig
advanced. Da kann das hier dagegen
einpacken.
Pass mal auf.
Wo ist der Label Champ? Bei mir im Kopf.
Der Label Champ.
Ja.
Pass mal auf,
wie hyper advanced der Label Champ war.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich glaube, da war
der Label Champ noch nicht wirklich fertig.
Der Label Champ, guck mal hier.
Da konnten Text platzieren, Text verschieben,
Schriftarten
ändern, was da anscheinend noch nicht funktioniert hat.
Der Label Champ war richtig gut.
Aber ich habe ihn nie fertig gebaut.
Der Preis Champ, den gibt es nicht mehr.
Den Preis Champ
gibt es nicht mehr. Da war mir das Aktualisieren
der Crawler zu aufwendig.
Äh.
Noch das alte Weltlayout.
Ah ja, guck mal, der Stream,
der war ja auch,
okay, der war von, ja doch,
der ist genau ein Jahr her.
Das neue Weltkit wollte ich mir auch
unbedingt mal angucken.
Oh, was ist denn hier los?
Real Opponent.
Drei Giftsubs. Dankeschön.
Der Sarix hat einen abgekriegt.
Pogu. Der hat es verdient.
Der Mod geht hier immer so schön.
Dann hat Semkano und Trockenhorn
noch eins abgekriegt.
Nice. Huge Subscriptions
hier.
Real Opponent.
Jetzt müssen
die Mod gesuppen.
Suppen vor allem. Die Mod gesuppen.
Wird reingesuppt.
Max, danke
für die Supps. Und übrigens auch, dass du so fleißig
weiter am Archiv baust.
Weil nicht, dass ihr etwa denkt, das Archiv
hätte ich gebaut oder so.
Dafür wird es viel zu regelmäßig
maintained. Das kann nicht von mir sein.
Das hat der Max,
also nicht ich, sondern der Serious Max hat das Archiv
gebaut. Ein wahrer
agiler Proggersman.
Und das Archiv
ist wirklich äußerst high IQ.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr überhaupt wisst, wie
high IQ das Archiv ist.
Das Archiv
hat, wie ihr vielleicht
seht,
ein
Transkript von jedem Stream. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich
das aufrufe. Zumindest, wenn
ich hier suche. Zum Beispiel
kekwe.
Dann durchsucht er im Text
Pass mal auf.
Hier. Transkript,
der durchsucht alles, was ich im Stream
gesagt habe. Guck mal,
ich kann sogar dahin springen. Pass mal auf.
kekwe?
Habt ihr es gehört?
Genau zu dem Moment, wo ich kekwe
sage. Und das
funktioniert per
AI-trainierter
GPU-beschleunigter
automatischer
Transkript-Erstellung
auf Serverseite.
Welche Linux-Distribution,
wenn die Firma vorschreibt, dass man Intune
braucht? Was ist denn Intune?
Microsoft-Shit, oder?
Geht die im Browser?
Wenn sie im Browser geht, ist egal, welche
Linux-Distribution. Wenn sie nicht im Browser
geht, dann wahrscheinlich gar nichts unter
Linux. Weil du dann irgendeine
offizielle Installation brauchst, die du wahrscheinlich
nicht unter Linux kriegst.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das Archiv funktioniert.
Tom, dankeschön.
Five gifted subs. Extremely
pogger subscriptions.
Wem hat da Tom denn subs gegiftet?
Zeig mal her. Dicklips.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an eine
Java-Idee.
Sava Impala.
Oscavian.
ByteKai und Klaus1305.
Extremely
pog.
Aber jetzt ist es gut, Leute.
Weil, ich gehe jetzt
pennen. Danke für die ganzen
subs, GIFs, für die
Bits, für die, was es nicht alles gibt. Und, dass ihr
hier wart, war eine sehr spontane
Geschichte. Ohne, dass
ich irgendwas vorbereitet hatte. Ohne, dass ich mir
irgendwas Gedanken gemacht habe. Ich habe einfach einen Stream angemacht.
Wir haben jetzt ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden lang
geschwätzt. Das, was
wir hier am besten können auf Twitch. Dafür ist es da.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten
Stream. Und dann,
und dann machen wir vielleicht,
nee, dann machen wir erstmal Mate Desktop fertig
und KDE. Und dann Neowim.
Alles gut, Leute. Bis dann. Macht's
gut. Cu. Boomer
müde. Boomer schlafen.
Badgittime.
Cu.